Speaker 1: We start again today with non-Trump
stuff.
There is lots of news to discuss.
And a blockbuster story about Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas breaking from ProPublica
about his acceptance of all sorts of high
value goodies from a billionaire Republican,
possibly criminal, certainly unethical.
And we will discuss it now.
We've had our suspicions about Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas.
Not only did his tenure on the Supreme Court
start under this cloud of allegation of sexual
harassment.
We also have seen this unbelievable story
in which he was presiding and potentially
presiding over cases related to the 2020 election,
as we knew that his wife, Ginni Thomas, was
an activist for the Bidens, stole that crowd
that was all wrapped up and tied win in with
the rioters of January six, 2021.
So and then, you know, 20 years in between
that you can fill in with other red flags
and question marks.
Well, there has never been anything like this
in Supreme Court history in terms of receiving
gifts.
There's a fantastic ProPublica piece that
you can look at.
We are going to look at a tweet thread from
ProPublica that gives us all of the most important
highlights.
And it starts for decades.
Judge Clarence Thomas.
Thomas has secret secretly accepted luxury
trips from a major Republican donor.
Newly obtained documents show Thomas has publicly
present presented himself as an everyman with
modest tastes.
In this documentary about him, he waxes nostalgic
about his fondness for Wal-Mart parking lots.
But and this is one of those great buts.
But Thomas's friendship with Dallas based
real estate magnate Harlan Crow has allowed
him to repeatedly experience luxuries well
beyond his means.
He's vacationed on Crows 162 foot superyacht
around the globe and flies on Crows Bombardier
Global 5000 jet.
That's a nice jet.
Nice jet if you can get one.
In June of 2019, Thomas boarded Crowe's private
jet to Indonesia for nine days of island,
hopping on the yacht.
Had Thomas chartered the jet and yacht himself,
could have set him back half a million dollars.
It wasn't Thomas's first time on Crowe's yacht.
The Michael arose.
He went on a river day in Savannah, a river
day trip in Savannah, Georgia, and an extended
cruise in New Zealand.
About a decade ago, while sailing around New
Zealand with Crow, he autographed a copy of
his memoir as a gift for a crew member.
By the way, that that's quite a narcissistic
move.
Thank you so much.
Here's my book.
The Justice has gone with Crowe to the Bohemian
Grove, the exclusive California all mail retreat,
and to Crowe's sprawling Texas ranch.
Every summer, Thomas typically spends about
a week at Camp Top Ridge, Crowe's private
resort in the Adirondacks.
Inside the top ridge hangs a photorealistic
painting of one of Thomas's visits to the
property.
The painting shows Thomas enjoying a cigar
alongside Crowe and chatting with conservative
powerbrokers like Leonard Leo.
If Leo's name sounds familiar, it's because
the longtime Federalist Society executive
is regarded as an architect of the Supreme
Court's turn to the right and recently received
$1.6 billion for a new conservative political
group.
Wow.
What brazen cronyism and corruption this continues
and you can read all of it.
I think the the important part here is as
follows.
While Thomas and Crowe have a genuine friendship,
these vacations put the justice in contact
with corporate executives and political activists
during just 1st July 2017 trip.
Thomas Fellow guests included executives at
Verizon, Pricewaterhouse Coopers.
Major Republican donors.
One of the leaders of the conservative American
Enterprise Institute.
These trips appear nowhere on Thomas's financial
disclosures, where justices are required to
list most gifts.
This is where we start to get into potential
criminality.
ProPublica looked at flight records, internal
documents and interviews with dozens of people
to uncover the travel details.
The failure to report the flights appears
to violate a federal disclosure law passed
after Watergate.
By accepting the trips, Thomas has also broken
long standing norms for judges conduct, ethics
experts say.
Nancy Gertner, a retired federal judge, says
It's incomprehensible to me that someone would
do this.
Virginia Kanter, a former government ethics
lawyer who has served in administrations of
both parties, says Thomas, quote, seems to
have completely disregarded his higher ethical
obligations.
Thomas did not respond to detailed questions.
So.
Without question, this corrupts public trust.
And justices are supposed to abide by a higher
ethical obligation in which not only should
you avoid actual bias and partiality, you
should avoid even the appearance of it.
And there are a couple of different stories
here.
One is that Clarence Thomas and his wife have
a long history of political entanglements
with absolutely no accountability.
We've known that for a long time.
Secondly, we have another law and order story
where my guess is and we'll have to wait and
see.
My guess is that right wingers will immediately
rush with knee jerk reactions to defend Clarence
Thomas and say these are paperwork crimes,
just like Trumps all paperwork crimes and
everybody's all paperwork crimes or whatever
the case may be.
So there will be no consistency there.
And then lastly.
Is Clarence Thomas like this, desperate to
be participating in this sort of stuff that
like it almost feels like, you know, a yacht
cruise and a trip to some degree, it all seems
kind of pathetic as well.
But now, going from just the suspicion of
lack of ethics to what seems like bona fide
criminality, the violations of law, as as
it regards these financial disclosures, will
it go anywhere?
I don't know.
With Clarence Thomas.
Clarence Thomas has had a sort of Teflon status
quo, much like Donald Trump did for many years,
although hopefully the latter is ending with
this week's arrest.
That's the latest really great report from
ProPublica.